et on revient maintenant dans les
Yvelines au Château de Rambouillet le
spectacle immersif secret défense
produit par Polaris et les monuments
nationaux proposent de revivre la
rencontre historique entre le président
américain Eisenhower et du général de
Gaulle au Château de Rambouillet en 1959
alors Mao deux roues de Rouvray
justement c'est la deuxième édition de
ce spectacle pour les téléspectateurs
qui ne connaissent pas secret défense
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire
découvrir un peu justement ce spectacle
immersif bien sûr secret défense c'est
un spectacle
immersif et historique avant tout c'est
un spectacle hors du commun c'est c'est
une aventure un parcours spectacle que
nous invitons le spectateur à vivre au
sein du Château de Rambouillet l'idée
c'est que le spectateur est invité à
revivre
un sommet d'État qui s'est réellement
déroulé en 1959 là on retrace en effet
la rencontre entre les présidents
Eisenhower et de Gaulle qui s'est
réellement déroulé au sein du Château de
Rambouillet du coup le 3 septembre 1959
et donc on immerge le spectateur
je veux j'essaye de pas de pas en dire
trop pour donner aussi un petit peu un
petit peu de suspense mais voilà on
invite les visiteurs à assister au
coulisses d'un sommet d'État donc en
passant par des bureaux d'écoute des
services secrets français en assistant à
une réunion entre les conseillers du
président américain et en bien sûr un
moment rencontrant les les fameux
présidents français et américains et
comment justement vous avez fait pour
retracer ce qui s'est passé en 1959 vous
avez fait appel à des archives comment
comment ça s'est passé tout à fait alors
ça c'est le travail de Charles mollet le
metteur en scène et auteur du spectacle
qui a donc passé des mois à retrouver
des archives en effet d'époque donc il
s'est inspiré de le spectacle est
entièrement inspiré de faits réel après
on y apporte notre pâte un peu fictive
et magique pour avoir cette part de
spectacle mais en effet tout ce qui est
dit on peut totalement le retrouver dans
des archives d'époque donc c'est des
documents écrits à la machine à écrire
c'est des photos c'est tout un tas
d'archives en effet qui ont aidé à
écrire ce spectacle de boutons et jouer
dans des
décors naturels est-ce que ça présente
des difficultés supplémentaires comment
comment est-ce que vous gérez ça
justement bien sûr oui ben on peut pas
faire forcément tout ce qu'on veut on
est quand même dans un château donc qui
est un monument historique donc on doit
s'adapter au lieu et donc après tous les
tous les décors sont faits en fonction
des lieux donc parfois on s'adapte à
chacune des pièces au matériau qui sont
présents et on et c'est là aussi que la
magie opère de notre côté parce que on
arrive à à recréer des choses en
construisant totalement des décors et
surtout qu'il y a aussi 600 bénévoles
donc ça fait complètement bien sûr sans
eux le spectacle n'existerait pas le le
spectacle est entièrement enfin tous les
participants de ce spectacle de sont des
volontaires donc on en compte entre près
de 600 sur ce spectacle qui sont donc
toutes les personnes que vous allez
croiser en venant voir ce spectacle
c'est-à-dire les personnes qui sont à la
billetterie à l'accueil qui sont à la
buvette du spectacle qui sont dans
chacune des pièces qui sont en coulisses
également ce sont tous des des
volontaires à l'oeuvre depuis trois mois
maintenant et est-ce que vous savez
pourquoi s'être intéressé justement à ce
pan de l'histoire et bien c'est une
c'est une période historique très
intéressante nous on parle surtout en
effet j'en ai pas parlé mais de la de la
guerre froide dans ce spectacle et il y
a des sujets évoqués pendant la guerre
froide qui sont finalement des sujets
assez actuels aujourd'hui aussi qui
reviennent et donc c'est c'était
intéressant de se pencher sur ce sur ce
moment de l'histoire surtout en ayant eu
le comme sujet le Château de Rambouillet
on trouvait que c'était vraiment
intéressant de se pencher sur ce cette
période de l'histoire pour ce spectacle
et du coup ça fait combien de temps que
vous travaillez sur ce projet puisque il
semble que ça devait débuter et par
rapport au covid ça a été reporté ça
fait quand même assez longtemps que vous
êtes dessus tout à fait le spectacle il
devait se dérouler pour la toute
première fois en 2020 en juin 2020 donc
on avait commencé les préparatifs chaque
volontaire avait reçu son rôle etc les
répétitions avaient commencé les travail
des décors avaient été bien avancés et
on a on a tout arrêté pendant du coup
près d'un an et on a repris en ah bah
non je dis ça mais plus puisque la
première a été deux ans plus tard donc
pendant deux ans le spectacle a été à
l'arrêt mais on a on a des participants
qui sont restés très fidèles et qui
étaient déjà là en 2020 qui se sont
réinscrits les dernières qui sont
toujours là cette année et qui nous
suivent mais du coup le spectacle devait
commencer en 2020 et la première du
spectacle a eu lieu en juin dernier 2022
et alors justement on va s'adresser
aussi aux téléspectateurs qui sont en
famille est-ce que les enquêtes est-ce
qu'il me semble que quand on est
visiteur spectateurs en tout cas de
secret défense on entre dans la peau
d'un agent d'un agent secret est-ce que
les enquêtes que doivent mener le l'été
spectateurs est-ce qu'elles sont
accessibles pour les enfants est-ce que
c'est simple c'est compréhensible alors
c'est il y a des termes c'est un sujet
de toute façon qui est plutôt destiné
aux adultes ou au lycéen qui aborde
cette période là sans aucun souci les
enfants je pense que il y a de toute
façon une période magique parce que il y
a des décors absolument extraordinaires
on fait monter on propose à une partie
des spectateurs de montée à bord d'une
voiture du cortège présidentiel donc on
fait tout un tour dans les dans les
allées du château avant de commencer le
spectacle et voilà donc les décors les
les musiques les le jeu des acteurs tout
ça je pense par là absolument tout le
monde et je pense qu'on a tous une part
d'enfants en nous qui fait que petit ou
grand on aime on aime ce spectacle
justement ça sera le mot de la fin merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation Mao on
le rappelle donc vous revenez pour
quatre weekends donc au mois de juin et
ça démarre dès le 2 juin au château d'or
Rambouillet alors justement vous aviez
reçu 18000 spectateurs l'an dernier donc
on vous souhaite de faire pareil voire
même plus et donc voilà beaucoup de
beaucoup de bonnes choses pour pour ce
mois de juin merci à vous